>> Chris: DAVID SPUN REPORTING
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE, THANK YOU.
IN JOINING US NOW, FORMER CDC
DIRECTOR DR. TOM FRIEDEN.
WHERE ARE WE WITH THIS VIRUS?
ARE WE PASSED THE PEAK, AND YOUR
PREDECESSOR IN THE JOB, THE
CURRENT CDC DIRECTOR, DR. ROBERT
REDFIELD TWEETED THIS ON FRIDAY.
"BASED ON 12 DIFFERENT
FORECASTING MODELS, WE WILL SEE
DEATHS EXCEEDING 100,000 BY JUNE
NOW.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I SAID THE SAME THING ABOUT
TWO WEEKS AGO AND MY TESTIMONY
IN CONGRESS.
TRAGICALLY, THIS IS A REALLY BAD
VIRUS, AND WE ARE JUST AT THE
BEGINNING.
WE ARE IN DIFFERENT PLACES IN
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE COUNTRY.
IN NEW YORK CITY, WHERE I AM
TODAY AND WHERE I LIVE, WE ARE
AT THE END OF THE BEGINNING.
IN SOME OTHER PLACES OF THE
COUNTRY, IT HASN’T YET HIT IN
FULL FORCE.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT THE
SAFER WE START, THE SOONER WE
CAN REOPEN OUR ECONOMY.
WE START SAFER, WE REOPEN SOONER
SOONER.
>> Chris: YOU SAY WE ARE JUST
AT THE BEGINNING, BUT PEOPLE ARE
ALREADY TALKING ABOUT A SECOND
WAVE EITHER NEXT FALL OR NEXT
WINTER.
ONE OF THE ADMINISTRATION’S TOP
EXPERTS ON VACCINES WHO HAS BEEN
MOVED OUT OF THAT JOB AND IS NOW
A WHISTLE-BLOWER TESTIFIED ABOUT
THE SECOND WAVE THIS WEEK.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THEY WILL LIKELY BE A
RESURGENCE OF COVID-19 THIS
FALL.
WILL BE GREATLY COMPOUNDED BY
THE CHALLENGES OF SEASONAL
INFLUENZA.
WITHOUT BETTER PLANNING, 2020
COULD BE THE DARKEST WINTER IN
MODERN HISTORY.
>> Chris: DR. FRIEDEN, IS HE
CORRECT?
>> NO ONE CAN PREDICT WITH
CERTAINTY WHAT’S GOING TO HAPPEN
WITH THIS VIRUS.
IT’S A NEW VIRUS.
WE THINK IT MAY SPREAD A LITTLE
BIT LESS IN WARMER WEATHER AND
THAT COULD HELP US, BUT I THINK
IT’S NOT RIGHT TO THINK OF A
SECOND WAVE.
UNFORTUNATELY, WE ARE LIKELY TO
SEE MULTIPLE WAVES IN DIFFERENT
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY.
WE KNOW THIS CAN SPREAD
EXPLOSIVELY IF IT GETS OUT OF
CONTROL.
THAT’S WHY WE HAVE TO BE SO
CAREFUL.
WE ARE ALL TIRED OF WAITING AT
HOME.
WE WANT TO GET OUT.
I WANT TO GET BACK TO THE GYM,
WE WANT TO GET BACK TO OUR LIVES
AND GET OUR ECONOMY BACK BUT AT
THE SAME TIME AS WE GO TOO FAST,
IT WILL BACKFIRE AND WE CAN SEE
EXPLOSIVE SPREAD THAT COULD
BRING US BACK IN.
FUNDAMENTALLY, IT IS NOT JUST A
LOCKDOWN THAT IS KEEPING US AT
HOME, IT’S THE VIRUS.
THE VIRUS IS THE ENEMY HERE.
AND YOGI BERRA SAID IF PEOPLE
DON’T WANT TO GO TO THE
BALLPARK, HOW ARE YOU GOING TO
STOP THEM?
IF PEOPLE AREN’T FEELING SAFE
GOING OUT, THEY ARE NOT GOING TO
GO TO DINE ANY AND SHOP AND DO
OTHER THINGS.
THAT’S WHY IT’S SO IMPORTANT
THAT TO GET OUR ECONOMY BACK
SOON, WE START SAFE.
>> Chris: YOU SAY START SAFE.
AS WE JUST SAID, 48 STATES HAVE
REOPENED TO SOME DEGREE, SOME
BUSINESSES, SOME PARKS AND
BEACHES, DO YOU THINK WE ARE
MOVING TOO SOON TO REOPEN?
>> OUT-OF-DOORS IS GREAT.
AND THERE WAS A VERY LOW RISK OF
SPREAD OUT-OF-DOORS SO BY ALL
MEANS, GO OUT, TAKE A WALK,
BICYCLE, ENJOY NATURE.
IS GOOD FOR YOU AND GOOD FOR
YOUR HEALTH AND THEY WERE SOME
BUSINESSES THAT ARE ESSENTIAL IN
SOME THAT CAN START WITH MINIMAL
RISK.
THERE WERE OTHER THINGS THAT ARE
GOING TO BE HARDER TO DO WITHOUT
A LOT OF SAFETY MEASURES.
SO WE ARE GOING TO SEE NOT
SHAKING HANDS FOR A WHILE, GOING
TO BE USING HAND SANITIZER A
LOT, GOING TO SEE FACE MASKS
WHERE IT IS SPREADING WIDELY
WHERE YOU’RE WITHIN 6 FEET OF
SOMEONE ESPECIALLY IF YOU WERE
INDOORS, THERE ARE THINGS THAT
WE CAN DO SO THAT WE CAN START
THIS SAFER.
DOESN’T MEAN YOU HAVE TO STAY
HOME FOREVER.
DOES MEAN WE HAVE TO BE CAREFUL.
YOU GET THE VIRUS, IT IS NOT
JUST ABOUT YOU GETTING SICK.
YOU COULD SPREAD IT TO YOUR
NEIGHBOR’S KID WHO HAS LEUKEMIA
AND THEY COULD GET DEATHLY ILL.
WE ARE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER
FIGHTING A VIRUS THAT IS A
REALLY DIFFICULT ENEMY TO FIGHT,
AND IT’S STILL OUT THERE.
IT’S GOING TO BE THERE.
THE MORE WE ARE SAFE FROM THIS
VIRUS, THE MORE WE WILL BE SAFE
FROM FLU AS WELL.
THOSE THINGS WE DO TO PHYSICALLY
DISTANCE WILL CUT DOWN OUR FLU
LEVEL AS WELL AND IF EVERYBODY
GETS THE FLU VACCINE THIS FALL,
THAT WILL BE HELPFUL.
JUST KEEP IN MIND, THIS IS A LOT
WORSE THAN THE FLU.
THIS IS TEN TIMES DEADLIER, IT
SPREADS MUCH MORE READILY, MORE
LIKELY TO KILL YOU, AND WE DON’T
HAVE ANY IMMUNITY NATURALLY, AND
WE DON’T YET HAVE A VACCINE.
>> Chris: I WANT TO PICK UP ON
THIS QUESTION OF WHERE WE ARE IN
THE VIRUS AND THE QUESTION OF
REOPENING BECAUSE WE HAVE HEARD
TWO VERY DIFFERENT ARGUMENTS
THIS WEEK FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND FROM DR. ANTHONY FAUCI.
HERE THEY ARE.
>> THERE IS A REAL RISK THAT YOU
WILL TRIGGER AN OUTBREAK THAT
YOU MAY NOT BE ABLE TO CONTROL.
>> NO ONE WANTS TO PLAY ALL
SIDES OF THE EQUATION.
>> Chris: I WANT TO POINT TO A
SPECIFIC STATE BECAUSE THERE WAS
A LOT OF CRITICISM WHEN GEORGIA
AND ITS GOVERNOR BRIAN KEMP
REOPENED A FEW WEEKS AGO, AND
THEY REOPEN SALONS AND GYMS.
EVEN GOT CRITICISM FROM
PRESIDENT TRUMP THAT IT WAS
MOVING TOO FAST, BUT WE HAVE NOT
SEEN THE KIND OF SPIKE THAT WAS
WIDELY FEARED WITHOUT REOPENING
IN GEORGIA WHICH RAISES THE
QUESTION, ARE SOME PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPERTS, I’LL INCLUDE YOU IN
THAT, ARE YOU BEING TOO ALARMIST
ABOUT THIS?
>> I DON’T THINK YOU CAN BE TOO
ALARMIST ABOUT WHAT THIS VIRUS
CAN DO.
A LOOK AT NEW YORK CITY OVER THE
PAST TWO MONTHS.
MORE THAN 20,000 DEATHS FROM
THIS VIRUS.
IT’S REALLY BEEN CATASTROPHIC,
BUT IT IS IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE ARE THINGS WE CAN DO
TO GO OUT MORE SAFELY, AND I
HAVE FRIENDS IN GEORGIA STILL
AND THEY DESCRIBED HIM A
PHYSICAL DISTANCING IN SHOPS,
PEOPLE DATE BEING VERY CAREFUL,
THAT’S IMPORTANT.
ALSO, KEEP IN MIND, THE VIRUS
MUTATES.
CHANGES, IT EVOLVES.
BUT FUNDAMENTALLY, WHEN IT
BEGINS THE SPREAD AGAIN, YOU
WON’T SEE THAT FOR A FEW WEEKS
BECAUSE IT TAKES ABOUT A WEEK TO
GET SICK AND ANOTHER WEEK TO GET
VERY SICK AND THEN YOU MAKE
OTHER PEOPLE SICK, SO ONCE THERE
IS THE RESUMPTION OF SPREAD, YOU
MIGHT NOT SEE THAT FOR A MONTH
OR TWO.
THERE’S A LAG HERE.
>> Chris: ON FRIDAY AS WE
REPORTED, PRESIDENT TRUMP
ANNOUNCED OPERATION WARP SPEED,
AN EFFORT TO MARSHAL THE
GOVERNMENT, PRIVATE COMPANIES,
THE MILITARY TO DEVELOP A
VACCINE AND 200 MILLION DOSES BY
THE END OF THIS YEAR.
HOW REALISTIC IS THAT?
200 MILLION DOSES OF A PROVEN
AND SAFE VACCINE BY THE END OF
THE YEAR?
>> IT IS ABSOLUTELY THE RIGHT
THING TO DO TO PULL OUT ALL THE
STOPS TO TRY TO MAKE A SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE VACCINE.
AND WE ALL HOPE IT WILL BE
AVAILABLE AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
JUST KEEP IN MIND, VACCINE IS
COMPLICATED.
YOU HAVE TO PROVE IT SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE, YOU HAVE TO MAKE HUGE
QUANTITIES, FIGURE OUT THE
DOSES, HOW MUCH OF IT, YOU HAVE
TO FIGURE OUT WHO GETS IT FIRST,
HEALTH CARE WORKERS WOULD BE
FIRST IN LINE AND YOU HAVE TO
GET IT OUT THERE AND EXPLAIN TO
PEOPLE WHAT IT IS, MONITOR TO
SEE IF THEY WERE ADVERSE
REACTIONS.
SO ABSOLUTELY, A VACCINE IS THE
SINGLE MOST IMPORTANT WEAPON WE
COULD DEVELOP AGAINST THIS
VIRUS, BUT WE DON’T HAVE ONE
YET.
WE HOPE WE WILL.
WE HOPE IT WILL BE SOON, BUT WE
CANNOT COUNT ON IT.
THAT’S WHY WE NEED TO GET USED
TO THE FACT THAT THE VIRUS IS
HERE FOR A WHILE.
WE ARE GOING TO CHANGE WHAT WE
DO SO WE CAN RESTART OUR ECONOMY
AND OUR SOCIETY AS SOON AND
SAFELY AS POSSIBLE.
>> Chris: I WANT TO PICK UP ON
THAT BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT SAID
WHILE HE’S PUSHING FOR A
VACCINE, THE COUNTRY IS COMING
BACK REGARDLESS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IT’S NOT SOLELY VACCINE
BASED.
OTHER THINGS HAVE NEVER HAD A
VACCINE, AND THEY GO AWAY.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SOMETHING
CLEAR.
IT’S VERY IMPORTANT VACCINE OR
NO VACCINE, WE ARE BACK.
>> Chris: CAN COVID-19 JUST TO
GO AS THE PRESIDENT SAID AND HOW
BACK TO NORMAL?
HOW BACK TO NORMAL CAN WE GET
WITHOUT A VACCINE?
>> IT’S UNLIKELY THAT THE VIRUS
WOULD SIMPLY DISAPPEAR.
THAT WOULD BE UNUSUAL BASED ON
WHAT WE’VE SEEN IN 200 COUNTRIES
AROUND THE WORLD.
BUT WE DON’T KNOW HOW IT WILL
BEHAVE OVER THE SUMMER.
WE DON’T KNOW HOW LONG IT WILL
PERSIST AND WHAT WILL HAPPEN
WITH IT.
NO ONE CAN PREDICT WITH
CERTAINTY, BUT ONE THING THAT IS
HIGHLY LIKELY IS THAT WE WILL BE
COMING TO A NEW NORMAL.
WE WON’T BE SHAKING HANDS FOR A
WHILE, USING LOTS OF HAND
SANITIZER, SAFE WHENEVER WE CAN
BE.
OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM NEEDS TO
BE A LOT SAFER.
WE WILL BE TRAVELING LESS, GOING
TO SEE CHALLENGES WITH DIFFERENT
COUNTRIES NOT LETTING PEOPLE IN
AND HAVING QUARANTINES AND WE
ARE LIKELY TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
OUTBREAKS IN PLACES LIKE NURSING
HOMES WHICH IS MORE THAN TWO
MONTHS AGO, GROUND ZERO FOR
THIS.
WE ARE GOING TO SEE THOUSANDS OF
DEATHS, BUT WE CAN SAVE A LOT OF
LIVES IF YOU CAN FOCUS ON BEING
IN THIS TOGETHER.
THERE IS ONLY ONE ENEMY HERE AND
IT IS THE VIRUS.
WE WERE ALL IN IT TOGETHER.
THE MORE WE ARE SAFE, THE MORE
WE WORK TOGETHER.
IS NOT ABOUT ECONOMY VERSUS
HEALTH.
PEOPLE ARE POOR, THEY’RE LESS
LIKELY TO BE HEALTHY AND UNLESS
WE CONTROL THE VIRUS, WE ARE NOT
GOING TO GET OUR ECONOMY BACK.
>> Chris: I’VE GOT ABOUT A
MINUTE LEFT IN A FINAL QUESTION.
AS FAR BACK AS I CAN REMEMBER,
THE CDC HAS ALWAYS BEEN THE LEAD
AGENCY AND HEALTH CRISIS LIKE
THIS.
I REMEMBER WHEN YOU WHERE THEY
AND THERE WERE VARIOUS
PANDEMICS, EBOLA AND THINGS LIKE
THAT, I WOULD BE TALKING TO YOU
AS THE LEAD PERSON FOR THE CDC
AND THE LEAD PERSON FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION.
THIS TIME, IT SEEMS LIKE THE CDC
HAS BEEN SIDELINED TO SOME
DEGREE.
THEY HAVE NOT HAD A PUBLIC
BRIEFING AND MORE THAN TWO
MONTHS.
ONE, DO YOU AGREE THAT THE CDC
ROLE HAS BEEN DIMINISHED AND YOU
THINK THAT IS REASONABLE OR DO
YOU THINK THAT’S A MISTAKE?
>> I WILL PERSONALLY FEEL SAFER
WHEN CDC IS SPEAKING REGULARLY
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY ARE THE WORLD’S EXPERTS IN
THIS.
NO OTHER DOCTOR, NO OTHER AGENCY
HAS THE DEPTH AND BREATH OF
EXPERTISE.
THEY CONTINUE TO DO GREAT WORK
AND IN FACT THEY ARE VOTING WITH
THEIR CLICKS.
THEY HAVE BEEN MORE THAN
1.2 BILLION CLICKS AND IT IS
STILL THE BEST PLACE TO GO FOR
OBJECTIVE INFORMATION,
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW TO
PROTECT YOURSELF AND YOUR FAMILY
AND YOUR COMMUNITIES.
SO I HOPE YOU WILL BE HEARING
MORE.
>> Chris: BRIEFLY, DO YOU
THINK IT’S BEEN A MISTAKE FOR
THIS ADMINISTRATION TO SIDELINE
THE CDC?
>> I THINK FIGHTING THIS
PANDEMIC IS LIKE FIGHTING WITH
ONE ARM TIED BEHIND YOUR BACK.
>> Chris: THAT IS BRIEF AND